[Music]
right now you and I are watching a
rotifer just chill and do its rotifer
thing the long thin strands of cilia
that make up its crown are whirling
around to grab food while the organisms
around it are caught up and diverted by
the vortex the rotifer has created it's
a charming scene as our so many of the
other scenes we've witnessed come out of
the micro cosmos whether you're watching
this at home or at work we're all
sharing in these strange and delightful
moments courtesy of our strange and
delightful microscopic friends and we
don't mean to add a layer of existential
dread to the proceedings but here's
something to think about by the time you
watch these scenes the stars the show
that come in and out of view are most
likely long gone perhaps they've been
put back in the sample jar or maybe
they've died on the slide they may have
even entered a protective cysts state
whatever path their lives have taken
since the moment they came into our view
we'll never be able to create these
exact scenes again so we're lucky today
to have a way to preserve and share
their lives in video and in the past
scientists turn to other artistic means
to document the micro cosmos including
illustration but sometimes pictures and
videos aren't enough sometimes the best
way to share what you've seen under the
microscope is well to share the actual
thing you're looking at these slides
that you're looking at now or purchased
from various auctions inside them are
diatoms collected from around the world
some from Rio de Janeiro others from
England and some from the Mediterranean
Sea these are places we might not be
able to visit easily and so who knows
when we'll be able to collect some of
their microscopic residents but thanks
to the fellow lovers of microscopes and
my
groves out there who collect and
preserve their samples we can actually
see a bit of what they've seen with our
own microscopes these prepared slides
are meant to be permanent the goal is to
be able to return to them at a later
date perhaps with fresh eyes or under a
new microscope maybe you've found a new
species and want to save it for later
observation or to convince others that
it's truly real or maybe you've just
found something that's beautiful or cool
something that you think others will
want to see and learn from whatever the
motivation the results as you can see
here are often stunning now there are
many different ways to prepare samples
from microscopic study because there are
many different types of specimens to
sample from microbes to pollen to organs
when we study our own samples here we're
using what's called a wet mount our
little buddies are swimming around in a
liquid in this case water we apply a bit
of this watery sample to the slide and
enclose it with a coverslip and then we
observe but to make these flights
permanent the microscopist has to do
things a little differently
again these techniques can vary but if
we were to follow one set of
instructions we found to prepare a
permanent diatoms sample we'd start by
allowing our watery microbe mix to
settle on a coverslip
until the thin layer of water has
evaporated away then we would add a
mounting medium to the slide and turned
the dry diatom coated cover slip onto it
allowing the medium to seep in and
preserve the organisms left behind
we are definitely simplifying this
process for narrative effect but we
wouldn't note that because of the
volatile compounds in the mounting
process the instructions also contain a
specific note to perform this procedure
in a fume hood among other safety
precautions so we recommend that anyone
seeking to make these prepared slides do
a bit more research on the best and
safest methods for their needs you may
have noticed already that the diatoms
we are watching in these prepared slides
very strong resemblance to the living
diatoms we've watched countless times on
this channel before but they're also a
bit different with the colors and shapes
shifted just slightly as if we're
watching them through a filter and this
is likely due to the use of acid to
remove their organic parts racing much
of their biological contents from our
view but leaving behind the stunning
silicon fresh jewels that diatoms encase
themselves in the result feels a bit
like roaming through the dioramas in a
Natural History Museum with scenes from
nature rendered on the other side of the
glass to suggest a living world that
does not actually live those dioramas
have the stillness and sense of distance
that a photograph does but they are also
their own direct experience that is
shaped by the setting you observed them
in in that same way these permanent
slides are their own unique perspective
of a static micro cosmos informed as
much by the people who made them as they
are by their later observers
and these slides have been letting
microscopists preserve and share the
objects of their fascination for
centuries around the mid 1800s
microscopy became kind of a thing
particularly in Britain manufacturers
were producing more affordable
microscopes and users were publishing
guides to help others use this tool to
navigate the unseen world amateur and
professional microscopists began to form
groups like the quick it microscopical
club united by the curiosities on the
other side of the lens the slides they
prepared carried everything from beard
hairs to insect exoskeletons to diatoms
and more than a century later people
still collect these slides studying
their contents not just to observe the
worlds mounted within them but also to
understand the people made them and just
as art museums have to verify and
conserve the works produced by old
masters museums and collectors have to
handle these microscope slides with care
as one collector noted these slides can
sometimes sell for thousands of dollars
attracting forgers whose false work
becomes apparent in fonts that are too
modern and cuts that are too uneven and
the authentic slides require maintenance
as well whether their surfaces need to
be cleaned of grime or their contents re
preserved the fascination and attention
these centuries old slides inspire feels
like a natural extension of microscopy
both as a hobby and a scientific pursuit
we've heard from many of you that the
footage we share on this show has made
you want to buy a microscope to sample
the world around you
to see what it contains and what are
these slides accept just another way
microscopists have been sharing the
natural world with each other these
slides don't show us the micro cosmos as
it once existed as much as they reflect
the journey the micro cosmos itself
health has taken through solvents and
hands and elements through microscopists
and collectors and then of course to you
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you
especially to all the people here on the
screen right now who are some of our
supporters on patreon where we now have
a $2 tier that includes access to a
journey to the micro cosmos discord and
if you want to learn more about that you
can go to patreon.com/scishow
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes and james weiss check out
Jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us there's always
a subscribe button somewhere nearby
you